english is the lingua franca or the
international language
of technology business and the sciences
in china alone there are more than 300
million english learners and over 50 000
language training schools
moving further away from the coastal
regions to the west the supply of native
english speaking teachers greatly
diminished
without high quality english instructors
english as a second language esl
students cannot learn how to communicate
effectively
so how can we help improve language
learning when a high quality english
speaking environment is not available
while many young people are learning
english diligently
in east asia their access to native
english speaking teachers
is very limited what they need is not
only a simple
traditional paper dictionary but a new
audio visual learning tool
with multiple useful functions the tool
should be able to detect input spelling
errors
guess the correct candidates read a word
or
example sentence combine both audio and
visual information together
in a photorealistic lip sync talking
hand
inkool helps language learners how inco
utilizes a new kind of spelling
correction
based on a phonetic search technology to
help end users practice their
pronunciation and listening skills
what's more
inco introduced a far more natural
sounding text-to-speech or tts engine
that really brings to life the millions
of bilingual sample sentences that are
mined from the web
continuously additionally a novel
lip syncing technology that
photorealistically captures
the mouth shape of an actual person you
can imagine like an english teacher
that really just makes e-learning
far more human far more authentic
and ultimately a more engaging user
experience
karaoke also known as ktv is a major
pastime amongst chinese people
we selected this form of expression to
make learning more engaging for the
target audience
the kdp function offers a low-cost
method
for creating a highly engaging
personalizable learning material
utilizing the state-of-the-art talking
header rendering technology
rather than repeatedly active speaking
the technology can synthesize
the audio and video content
automatically
this has the potential to further
bridging the classroom
and e-learning scenarios where a teacher
can generate his own talking head for
students
to take home and learn from now we can
put words into the computer's mouth by
employing
text to speech tts technology in tts
input text is converted into speech
in the training phase the speech signals
are first converted to the sequence of
feature vectors
the exact feature sequence then you
touching
parametric statistical models namely
hidden mac models the algorithm has
three processing stages
hmm trajectory generation sources
construction
and optimal concatenation we use hmm
models to generate high quality speech
trajectories of three speech parameters
pitch
gain and short time spectral envelope
parameters the generated trajectories
are used to find waveform candidate
tiles
where the optimal sequence is found
finally highly intelligible and natural
speech
is synthesized the quick brown box jumps
over the lazy dog
read my lips our talking head technology
works by visually capturing different
sound articulations of a speaker
in roughly 30 minutes of video the
captured audio visual recording will be
used as the training data for building a
photorealistic talking head
as the model may move her head during
recording head pose normalization is
applied to normalize all frames to fully
frontal
the computer extracts analyzes and
parameterizes all relevant mouth images
and forms a library of lip images and
the corresponding speech signals
a statistical hmm is automatically
trained to characterize
how lips move to articulate different
speech sounds
in synthesis the trained statistical
model can then predict the trajectory of
lip movements for any given text input
the hmm predicted trajectory is used as
a guide to select a succinct and smooth
mouth sequence from the image library
here we show you the rendering results
from left to right they are the original
recording the hmn predicted trajectory
and the final
synthesized lips movement look out of
the window and see if it's raining
in the final step the best match mouth
sequence is stitched back to a full head
video
in a natural lip sync and photorealistic
talking head is animated
the last feature aims to guess a user's
intended word phonetically
from a large amount of data a
statistical model can be trained to
learn the conversion rules between
spelling and pronunciation
phonetic similarity search can suggest
the similar sounding words candidates
according to the input query guessed by
the user
it is a third problem that we can solve
the admiring phonetic similarity
between the input query and the similar
sounding words
the spelling is first converted to the
most probable phoneme sequences
by a letter to sound module search is
performed using dynamic programming by
measuring the phonetic distortions
between two phoneme strings in a
phonetic try a prefix tree where the
keys along a path are
phoneme strings and the values are
letter strings
the service has become very popular in
china used by more than 10 million
unique users per month
it was also recognized by the wall
street journal by winning its asian
innovation 2010 reader's choice award
this computer-assisted audio visual
language learning assistant
can become more intelligent by
incorporating more
advanced research results in speech
recognition
speech synthesis and natural language
processing
it can hear and speak read and compose
or even guess the learner's mind by
predicting his
intended work